I think I could speak for all the world
bank employees it's a it's a job that is
very it gets it grabs you really
strongly and you you do get up early in
the morning and you look forward to they
are very interesting work because what
could be more interesting than to work
on some 150 countries on about 100
sectors and on global issues from such
an outpost as the World Bank which is
owned by 185 countries of the world and
from which you do look at the world as
if it was a whole planet not from the
country point of view but from the sort
of overall global point of view so it's
a very interesting job to be in and
you'd get to learn a lot of things about
a lot of countries and a lot of people
and the culture of the institutions is
interesting it's one where there are a
hundred and fifty or sixty nationalities
in the house and you never think about
the nationality of your colleagues you
forget about it everyone has the same
jargon and code words and you forget
that someone is Italian or Bangladeshi
or Tanzania so it is a little bit it has
the culture of the world as I would wish
it to have I would wish the world had
that sort of culture one day it's beyond
the nation state and the nationality
culture it's sort of one level above and
that also makes it very fascinating and
the third thing that had me taking at
the World Bank it's a very libertarian
institution there was a lot of room for
debates on what worked and what didn't
work there were a lot of arguments
academic arguments or even practical
arguments one way or the other and you
could do many things and I did in my
time I pioneered many new things and I
was never whistled back and that way
that was part of the reasons why I so
like the institution